y at-il eu des dysfonctionnements au
sein de l'université de tours dans la
gestion du cas de cet étudiant en
médecine accusé de viols et d'agressions
sexuelles par cinq femmes en 2020 oui
selon l'inspection générale de
l'éducation du sport et de la recherche
qui vient de rendre un premier bilan de
ces investigations aucune procédure
disciplinaire n'aurait été prise à
l'encontre du mis-en-cause de 24 ans
alors que l'université avait
connaissance des faits qu'on lui
reprochait retour sur cette affaire dans
la sphère avec sa dalle colin
le rapport d'inspection pointe un
manquement l'université aurait dû lancer
une procédure disciplinaire et ce
d'autant plus qu'une enquête pénale est
en cours nous sommes fin ou 2020 un
jeune homme est accusé de faits de viols
et d'agressions sexuelles sur cinq
femmes entre 2013 et 2020 deux premières
plaintes viennent d'être déposées le
doyen auditionne alors le 14 septembre
2020 l'élève et ses parents puis des
plaignantes il est possible de
superposer une procédure judiciaire et
une procédure disciplinaire
ici dans ce cas d'espèce on a estimé que
la procédure judiciaire est insuffisante
ce fut manifestement nra doyen
qui a écarté l'étude des étudiantes qui
n'auront pu rencontrer ces auditions se
font hors de tout cadre légal l'avocat
de quatre plaignantes dans cette affaire
m marc morin s'étonne de l'initiative du
doyen et si celui ci n'a pas la culture
juridique comme le pointe le rapport
l'université de tours comme dans toute
université il ya un service juridique
qui connaît parfaitement les procédures
disciplinaires et qui sait parfaitement
dans quels cas on peut et on doit
initier procédure disciplinaire le
président de l'université de tours est
le supérieur hiérarchique du doyen de la
faculté de médecine
supérieur seul capable justement de
lancer une procédure disciplinaire
l'inspection de l'enseignement supérieur
relève à côté de cela une possible
incompréhension entre le procureur et le
doyen contacter le procureur est clair
enquêtes pénales et disciplinaires sont
distinctes et il n'a jamais été question
de favoriser l'une à l'autre mais le
rapport de conclure que l'université n'a
pas cherché à étouffer la faire pour
autant de son côté la présidence de
l'université n'a pas répondu à nos
sollicitations